The jogan Experience did you see this
[__] thing that happened in
California where this woman stabbed her
boyfriend 108 times and they let her go
with the community service they said
that she was psychotic from smoking
marijuana which is so I don't smoke by
the way I smoke I haven't smoking a long
time I ain't never thought about stabing
one person ever forget about someone
that you're in a relationship with times
and the judge said that the defense was
that she had a psychotic break from I
think it was one hit so I had a bad
panic attack from one
hit yeah you could have a panic some
strong especially if you're not a
regular smoker no it wasn't was it a bon
head or a joint it was a joint what what
it was was was it was my first time
actually
inhaling you went Bill Clinton the way
before no seriously and just all I
remember I couldn't stop coughing not
realizing each cough is just sending
more T to my system and that was the
real like that was me really smoking for
the first time and let's just say all I
remember I'm sitting on a couch having a
massive panic attack watching Eddie
Murphy
Raw and and how and how I knew I was
[__] up was I've watched raw multiple
times and never have I not laughed my
ass off and I remember sitting there
watching and I was like this is not
funny this is not I like oh dude
something's wrong with you dude you were
just freaking out yeah you can freak out
man yeah so this is the story well I
mean that just said that this New York
po was just really strong weed 30% weed
whatever whatever one hit she stabbed
her boyfriend 108 times I don't care if
she took 18 bong hits and herself and
the dog what well maybe there's
something wrong with her and she
shouldn't get [__] community service
that's insane herself she stabbed her
dog and then repeated stabbed herself
repeatedly after deputies were called to
their apartment okay after the I mean
first of all when people kill people
they often kill themselves this happens
to men who kill their girlfriends or
their ex-girlfriends they often times
they'll shoot themselves it happens all
the time she found out he was cheating
well whatever it was the whole thing is
she received just two years of probation
100 hours of community service and no
prison time I would believe that more if
it was alcohol even alcohol doesn't make
any saying it would have to be like
crystal meth mixed with t with [__]
angel dust yeah just the lawyers were
asked to describe the difference in her
case in a fatal drunken driving crash
was Goldstein chocked up to awareness
noting that I don't know what her how
you say her name whatever her last name
is did not know she was what she was
getting herself into as Amelia provided
the pot but did not show her the warning
on the
label what as far as a d Y is concerned
that person knowingly and consciously
drinks to excess and decides to get
behind the wheel of a car in Mrs
whatever her name is case she took a hit
of what she believed to be a legal
consumer product in the sanctity of uh
Mr Amelia's home as they sat on his
couch with no plans to go drive home
later that evening that 43 times in her
neck she stabbed herself she stabbed
herself 43 times in the neck oh my god
well that's the marks on her neck didn't
she really try that hard well listen
people try to kill themselves after they
kill somebody look if you're if you're
lying there and your your boyfriend is
got 108 stabo and you're like oh my God
my life is over I'm going to jail for
the rest of my life but why the dog cuz
she's [__] just an angry lady I mean
why did she she just had a psychotic
break and I don't think it was the week
who knows I think she found out
something she did not want to find out
she just snapped but it might not be
that I mean she might be [__]
legitimately crazy but either way two
hours or 100 hours of community service
in 2 years of probation is [__] nuts
you just killed somebody imagine the
rules reversed imagine it was a man who
stabbed his wife 100 or his girlfriend
108 times under the jail he'd be under
the jail death sentence experts for both
the defense and the prosecution
concluded the pot she smoked caused her
to slip into a psychotic State now
here's the the story you can have
psychotic breaks from marijuana it is
possible it's possible to have
schizophrenic breaks for marijuana it's
well documented with certain people that
have yes so but either way nobody it
doesn't make any marijuana is not a
violent drug it's not the kind of drug
that makes you want to hurt somebody and
keep in mind this is coming from
somebody who does not like marijuana
yeah at all I don't believe that it
sounds insane I don't believe it sounds
insane there probably a lot more to that
story yeah very much so very very very
much she stabbed herself in the neck
like Jesus that's crazy the deputies
used a stun gun on her four times and
another deputy hit her with the metal
baton multiple times before knocking the
knife out of her hand while she was
stabbing herself or him I guess herself
I it doesn't say who she wasab she proba
might have started stabbing herself when
the cop showed up too like who knows
yeah yeah I mean the whole thing is nuts
I mean but then again like I've seen
like I I watched a video on the way up
on the way up here I didn't watch it I
was listening to it while I was driving
on the way up here and like it was this
girl I guess she was drunk or something
and the cops were trying to arrest her
and she completely lost it I mean
screaming at the top of her lungs like I
mean complete psychotic breakdown yeah
just to avoid accountability of the fact
that she was driving drunk so I mean
it's there's some people that are out of
their [__] minds but I just don't
think two years of probation is enough
for that I mean sounds insane I think
that goes without saying it sounds so
insane that the judge said that yeah I
want to see the Jud I want to talk to
the judge whoa hold on too they were
only dating for three
weeks oh my God so even if you cheated
on her what the [__] that doesn't dating
each other for about three weeks wow she
worked as an audiologist what is that
sound and the dude was an accountant
maybe she's stabbing because he's boring
it's a horrible tragedy all the way
around Schwarz said it's a tragedy for
the victim and his family it's a tragedy
for my client and family yeah well it's
certainly a tragedy there's no but High
potency marijuana should put you into
place where you're terrified of
everything you just want to exactly not
that you have the ability to grab a
knife and stab a guy 108 times that
sounds nuts that sounds so
nuts it said in September they' got the
murder charge dropped to involuntary
manslaughter after it was determined she
lost her cognitive abilities because she
was in the throws of psychosis M yeah
maybe but I mean I I just don't think
that absolves you of responsibility you
know the the thing about it is you
there's no way to know what was going on
in her head which is the thing like you
know a friend of mine sent me a video
Tim Dylan sent me this video of these
schizophrenics in Downtown LA it's so
crazy there's so many of them and these
these all these different people are
walking on the street just screaming at
people who aren't there and just yelling
into the sky I
had my old place in Dallas I I had a guy
call him
Richie I don't really know his name I
just call him that cuz he likes to stand
outside my door and just have loud
conversations with himself like he would
do it wasn't like like all the time but
it'd be like once every like three or
four months and he would just be stand I
don't know why he picked my door to do
it I don't know I never engage with them
or interacted with them I would just
hear my D window like they're goes
Richie um but man the mind is so weird
it is you know it's like just the fact
that a human being forget about under
the state of marijuana PCP whatever just
the fact that there's something if
you've never stabbed any before anyone
before there's something that someone
can give you that can motivate you to do
that well you've never done that before
you never stabbed anybody and then all a
sudden you stab some guy you've been
dating 108 times the mind is just so
weird
yeah